I think we should start playing I'm
gonna call in my friend Erin Blair to
help explain get us into the game
what do you always cuttle in like a bug
that's just don't scuttle in like that
just walk in like a guy that's or walk
that's just my walk okay I'm sorry
we don't get the best people we're just
gonna watch a quick cut scene of told me
that told me 13 he's come to the village
of see wha
to get the apple of Eden which is gonna
hopefully give him superhuman powers and
byuk is gonna kind of stand in his way
and okay I'll just start the thing awful
it's fine what an awful man fine it's
just let's just you're an awful person
that's totally okay you suss that out I
wasn't sure I just thought that was a
douchebag
don't care about his sleep habits no I
had trouble sleeping I need something to
help me sleep oh that was sweet
I don't want to beat this kid out of
this guy yes these chores that's all
these games are is a list of chores Oh
see look at this carrying the bodies
yeah there you go in this is what you do
right here back up up the hill up the
hill and drop it the pilot Doan carries
a dead body like Aaron Rodgers yeah
here's your body how's it feel feels
good huh gone eagle and you can scope
stuff out before you go into a hideout
cave an eagle so you fly out you can you
can kind of scope Kyle it's a crow crows
whatever so I'm just looking for stuff
now it's a good for the game well yeah
pretty you know what I have to say this
is nice to get away this is I think what
I'm doing is really look at that it's
fantastic
you're good at this sneaking stuff
you're really good it just started
creeping around
being crazy yeah it's not it's not
becoming like a good attribute community
what happened are you kidding what's
gonna hit and run hit and run they're so
you're telling aren Rogers I'm just
sayin strategy-wise I think you should
go
you